1, 2, 3, 4.
Hey!
Metallica's that family I
never had or always wanted
that I found in a band.
ANNOUNCER: Artist of the
year goes to Metallica!
We all know each other, and
we continue after 40 years
to learn more about each other.
We're going to talk
about how we write songs,
How to get the best out of
everyone without dominating,
We're going to break down some
of the most classic Metallica
songs,
and we're going
to give you a bad---
performance.
As far as lyrics
go, I will have
spaces where I need a
vocal, and then I'll
search through some
of my one liners,
and go, "oh,
rhythmically, that fits.
So I'll plug that in and
start building around that."
When you're in a band,
communication is key.
If you have a problem, talk
about it with a level head.
A mantra for us is "whatever's
best for the project."
That helps to quell the ego.
In the early days, there
was so much just "pch."
There's been times
when it's been fractured
and it looks like we were
on the verge of breaking up.
30 years ago, we'd come off
stage and we'd go you "f-----
that up and you f----- that up."
Nowadays we'd go, "ha, ha, ha.
That was really funny.
That was a crazy variation."
At the end of the day, it's
a f------ rock-and-roll song.
When you're in a band, the
commitment is to music,
but after a while, you
realize it's a real commitment
to each other.
That's what being in
a band's all about,
coming together to
create great things.
If there's anything
in what we're
about to share that in
any way inspires you,
influences you, makes
you want to jump
into any creative endeavor,
particularly music,
then we've done our job.
I'm James Hetfield.
I'm Robert Trujillo.
I'm Kirk Hammett.
I'm Lars Ulrich.
We are Metallica, and
this is MasterClass.